stunning new report from The Associated
Press claims that Donald Trump was
seriously considering a Venezuelan
invasion in late August of 2017
there was actually a meeting in late
August where sanctions on Venezuela were
discussed and at the end of the meeting
the meeting was sort of wrapping up and
Donald Trump asked his top aides who
were around him why can't we just invade
Venezuela and according to the senior
administration official who spoke about
this meeting people in the room were
stunned which is a common theme when
Donald Trump speaks then Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson and then national
security adviser HR McMaster both of
whom interestingly are no longer working
for Trump immediately started to explain
to Trump why invading Venezuela is not a
good idea and as the conversation is
described McMaster and other people in
the room kind of took turns explaining
to Trump the different reasons why it's
a bad idea how it could backfire how it
could completely squander the support
that has been built among other Latin
American leaders to push back against
the Venezuelan regime for going down the
dictatorial path and apparently the
experts in the room didn't really decide
on 'old Trump because the next day Trump
was talking to friends about the quote
military option in Venezuela to remove
Nicolas Maduro from power and then Trump
still kept going with it the following
month in September when he spoke to four
different Latin American leaders
including the Colombian president and
all four of those leaders said to trump
in abundantly clear terms yeah we don't
we don't want to use the military option
in Venezuela and this is how volatile
the guy is right on a whim he's talking
about the sanctions solution seems
complicated what about just invading
Venezuela and even his top advisors with
relatively significant experience
although maybe not Rex Tillerson can't
talk him out of it and I would really
want to talk it through because if
you're white if you're a regular viewer
of the David Pakman show you probably
know that I don't support the Venezuelan
regime and there's the strain of the
left it's a sort of what I call a
Leninist strain that loves Hugo Chavez
and loves nicolas maduro and seems to
think that venezuela is just great and
that these are truly progressive
populist leaders I'm not in that group
right I don't support authoritarian
dictators I don't care whether the
rhetoric sounds progressive their
implementations are total strongman
authoritarianism and I don't support
that and no leftist should that being
said an American invasion of Venezuela
is an obviously disastrous idea the
United States is one of the reasons that
so many Latin American countries have
people wanting to come to the United
States legally or illegally and I've
talked before about how American foreign
policy towards Latin America can either
drive people to try to come to the
United States illegally or it can
improve conditions in their home
countries so that people will be more
likely to want to stay and an American
invasion of Venezuela would only
perpetuate the conditions that make
people want to come to the United States
in the first place that's number one now
number two look at the history of
American interventions in Latin America
absolute unmitigated disaster and if the
Maduro regime is to be pushed out of
power and i want it to be pushed out of
power because it's an abomination it
needs to be with as little american
involvement as possible I want Maduro
out right if Maduro and Chavez have been
atrocious spectacles in Venezuela but a
US military led intervention is not what
should remove Maduro from power and to
circle back to the Trump foreign policy
aspect of this remember that we were
told by the pro Trump crowd and actually
by the anti Hillary crowd which are not
always the same groups there are
overlapping groups in some way we were
told Hillary if she wins we'll start a
ton of wars but Trump wouldn't I'm
asking you now what military
intervention has Trump opposed as
president he's been in favor of a ton of
them he's been talked out of it by aides
or by foreign leaders Syria were it not
for the Russia factor we might already
be way more involved in Syria Iran if
you want to do something in Iran
certainly you've got to get out of that
Iran deal which Donald Trump is doing
Venezuela okay it seems like he was
talked out of it
North Korea if his deal backfires how
quickly will the military option be back
on the table I'm not seeing that Donald
Trump is far less likely to get involved
in Wars than Hillary Clinton would have
been you know I just blame this
statement on Trump's incompetence right
because he doesn't do the homework he
doesn't read the briefings every day
right but he still wants to contribute
to the conversation so when his advisers
are talking about what we can do you
know economically or militarily
he just has out of left out of the
conversation because he doesn't really
know those intricacies do you think that
yes so he says well why don't we just
invade the country it might be useful if
he read those daily briefings like maybe
there would be something communicated
there which would leave him and with an
understanding of why it's not a great
idea to think about just invading but
again this is a guy who wasn't totally
sure why it wasn't a good idea to
consider using nuclear weapons on Europe
during the presidential campaign so yeah
seem like he has this tendency I think
he asked three times why we couldn't use
nuclear weapons against North Korea
you'd have to explain that to him three
times yeah it should only take twice two
explanations right before a normal
person gets it